I'm Dan Soder and this is me answering the internet.
Would you rather know when you're going to die or how are you going to die,
dude? I'm a hypochondriac. How I'm going to die? I don't care what?
Just tell me what it is so I can smoke cigarettes and get back
to it. I miss smoking so bad. That's how good tobacco is to like,
you want to know when you're in it. I'm like, I don't care.
Can I smoke smoke right now? Cause I seriously did the opposite way.
I would say if, when I'm going to die,
if I get a diet 80 I'll smoke and then I don't care. Go fast in a car.
No car crash. I'm going 90. Everywhere.
I'm laying on the gas. You gotta look at it. You gotta, you gotta,
you gotta jump the route on this. You gotta be like, Oh. I didn't die.
Smoking butts. Next question.
Would you rather be blind or dickless.
What? Why is tough?
Yeah, sure.
So it was being dickless you just got to walk around to just be weird things
like, Oh, wind would hit and you'd be like, ah, you should have to be,
feel that I'm a Dick and my jeans it'd be stuff that you would never realize you
would miss your Dick for coming out of a pool, being blind.
You don't feel around.
I hope I have a way better shot to finding the woman of my dreams feeling faces.
How great is it to walk in a room to start grabbing faces, Palm and people?
What he is? Who are you? All right. I'm bad at remembering names.
So I'd be like, Oh, is that? And that is Steve. His second motion, his eyebrows.
What kind of it.
Would you rather have sex with a girl who has banged a thousand dudes or one
animal?
How afraid or what dude? I would,
I'll take a thousand chickens bend a thousand dudes every time.
Cause first off that means, that mean beach. That is like,
that's like Conan on the wheel.
She's pushed the wheel enough times or like she knows what she's doing or what
are you going to be like now let me a sheep.
You have to be so insecure to be like, I'd rather a barnyard animal.
Cause I don't want to follow a guy that might've been good at sex.
Just give me that goat. Come here. I can't a chick.
That's bang a thousand dudes. I wouldn't give a. I'd be like, all right,
I'll give her three stripes. Like a general. I'd be like, this is my lady.
She has been to war.
Would you rather be hooking up with a girl and prematurely come in your pants
and she finds out or start crying in the middle of the sex.
I feel like you can rebound easier from crying during sex.
I feel like I would rather cry during sex because I could be like, it's just,
we're in the moment. And I love this so much. It's supposed to be like,
don't touch me. Don't touch me. And then she's like, what happened? You're like,
Oh. Oh. I'd be.
Like a little more normal than.
Crying. You think you busting your pants, you busting your pants game over.
You're not moving on. You cry during sex. She might be like,
this guy loves me. Yeah, there you go. I'd rather cry during sex.
Would you rather be bald by the age of 20 or five?
Three with a full head of hair. Short guys getting no love.
give me seven feet bald as a. You can have sex with anyone you want,
but they die immediately after who or O or just
who do you have sex with?
Awesome.
I got one for you. A Casey Anthony.
Oh, that's a great answer.
Call me, call me Dick justice. That's for Kaylee.
What a weird thing to say after you come and kill ya. That one was,
I don't think that was wrong. I think I'm right.
Other than everyone agrees with me. You don't have the balls to push it.
I'm coming for that wrong.
you. That little girl.
Would you rather have a girl who talks too much during sex or is completely
silent? Do that talk too much complete.
Have you completely signed thing? I've gone through it. It is not good.
Heavy nostril breathing
feels like you're it feels like having sex with a quadriplegic. It's hard.
It sounds like you're just wasting their time. Like,
Am I putting you through a a workout? Is this a, is this a spin class?
I can't do that too much. I'm afraid a book is going to shoot right out. Yeah.
Talks way too much.
Would you rather wake up to a every morning or a hundred dollars under your
pillow? Every morning. I'm going to say a hundred bucks. Really?
Have you ever gotten a beach when you're,
when you're not really into it and it's the morning and you feel weird.
It's like, it's like turning down a great dinner. You feel bad. You're like,
I understand this is great, but I'm in a weird, I got a fart.
Maybe I got a poop. Sometimes I gotta poop for thing in the morning.
I'm not taking the beach right then and there. That's just disrespectful to her.
Just waking up to a crisp $100. Let's go out for breakfast.
Get that beach around 2:00 PM.
Would you rather get your girlfriend pregnant when you're 16 or get
your wife pregnant when you're 60? What a dumb question?
60 all day. Maybe I'm around. Maybe.
I'm not.
I'm out of here. 60. My dad clocked out at 48.
Would you rather sit on a cake and eat a Dick or sit on a
Dick and eat a cake? Best question of the day was really hurts.
I mean, it's going to hurt you through it.
I'm going to sit on a cake and eat a Dick.
Cause I just feel like I can just pretend the Dick something else.
Eating cake with a Dick in my butt will ruin cake forever.
Does that make any sense? I don't know something, you know,
just like an Otter pop, like a, like a flushed flavored Otter pop.
But you just sit in there with a Dick in your and then someone you're at your
grandma's birthday and she's like try some cake and you're like, I can't,
I got bouffed out to it. I'm not ruining cake.
Would you rather stub your toe,
get a brain freeze or bite your char your tongue cheek randomly three times a
day. Uh, stub my toe.
Cause I feel like you're going to shake that off stump toes.
It hurts a little bit at first, a little bit at second. And then it goes away.
This is literally a couple of seconds. Total real heart.
That rush where it goes off your toes,
your brain crazy versus biting your cheek and your tone.
Because then it's talking, eating everything's affected brain freeze.
I did learn the trick of flipping your tone. You push the top,
but that's some that works most of the time. I do stubbed toe all day.
Like, uh, like in the wind knocked down Hill. It really doesn't happen.
Once you become an adult.
Do I get brain freeze all the time? I also, yeah, I also eat ice cream.
Like I'm 10.
You eat ice cream fast enough. It doesn't matter how old you are.
It.
Every Sunday I get very stoned when I get off the road and I eat a pint of 20
and I'm pretty good for one brain freeze a Sunday.
There's one brain freeze where you just see me walking around my apartment
going.
Mediterranean mint. Not you too.
Would you rather be twice your age or half your height? Twice my age.
I'm not gonna be three feet seven. I don't know. Do I want to be three feet?
I'm six. Three. So that would make me three.
Who's good at math. Come on, huh? Because this is a three, one and a half.
I'd be what? Come on, man. I'll be 70 all day,
because guess what my rule is. If I hit 70, I'm smoking cigs again, next one,
camel lights. I miss you.
Would you rather have a good hand job from your grandmother or a bad hand job
from your grandmother? Did my is from Oklahoma there.
Ain't no way she's tossing out mediocre hedges. I say, I,
you get in and get a good hand job. And you're like, Oh grandpa.
You're a lucky man. You pop. And like, can I get a reason?
So many good snacks after you come get those strawberries in their package?
What STD would I be willing to get to pass on to someone? I mean,
isn't that everyone's answers HPV. Cause that's the real thing
is do we act like the nineties and two thousands didn't happen? Uh,
I would probably say gonorrhea. Yeah. You know a little drip. You get angry,
take a pill. You're good. Who would I, Oh,
I'd go head hunting. I'd go back for some old broken hearts for that.
No, you want.
To go get something to hang out. I up.
Starting today. If you get $10,000 a day for every day, you don't.
How many days could you go without jerking off.
10 K a day. Stop the tape gravy train.
And I think I could get.
One month.
For 10 K a day. If I knew it was 10 K day, literally physically.
I don't think actually you're right.
Cause I remember I don't jerk off when I go to my grandma's.
That's why the hand job question was so hard and uh,
I made it like five days,
one time and I was about to just start punching the wall because that 30 days.
All right. Hey, wildly overestimate your wild little recipe, 15 days.
And that's tough, but I feel like I can do it 150 K
15 days. I feel like I can. Now here's the question.
Can I just unload before the 15 days dry out?
Twist the sponge? No, just completely dry bone, dry walking in.
I got 15 days. I think by day 14,
I have to be in a cage by myself. Yeah.
I'm just like a tiger walking back into it.
Better not be windy or nice weather because if it's hot, I'll break,
it's got to be cold.
Cold.
Can I do mushrooms a lot? So I don't want to touch my Dick.
Have you ever done mushrooms? Oh, you do not.
Your penis feels very silly in your hands. When you do mushrooms,
I've never touched my Dick on mushrooms and be like, yeah, I'm always like.
What is this? This is the source of all these problems.
This little thing. This number trunk.